no reason to be nervous I'm the one
who's about to propose to my girlfriend
you're joking right
I don't joke about love Anders Ponder's
I used to cut myself to Dashboard
Confessional I love love okay here's the
joke
what did three girls say to the one dude
so you like really love her that's cool
well she's really the only chick that
lets me make out with her until my
tongue hurts she's kind of my last shot
at lifelong happiness wish me luck
all right don't blow it don't blow it
like I'm about to hey buddy what
couldn't help but overhear you're being
a little nervous Nelly Furtado yeah I
guess you need a friend
nah man no and don't do it Blake try it
once man look at me man I got it all
figured out buddy did cause you're I to
do that no I was born with that okay
yeah give a shot gotta help I'll tell
you that much well look no further you
marry me
hi Murray are you kidding it I'm sixteen
debatably the sexiest age we do in this
you're gonna out on me chicken no
I I don't know you can knock off all
that God stuff right and just bugged me
hard hit that caboose no Adam my faith
means everything to me not having yeah
duh you dick your dumb dumb
obviously that's where I'm proposing to
you you know what Adam I think we should
take some time off and I'll pray for you
you'll be my prayers
you still want me to call you out of
class on Tuesday I'll take you to Sonic
Wow okay you give your heart to someone
right and then just rip it out in the
heart cavity area college sucks it's
stupid
really yeah I'm having a really great
time I mean of course I'm from a boring
small town with one stoplight so this is
fun for me how religious are you well
wish this was real we would have
murdered her hey it's Blake right you
lose I saw you on campus earlier and
I've got to say pretty convincing French
police officer thank you how'd you like
to be the understudy of Javert and this
year's production of lame is I
understand how about you study under my
nutsack oh sorry is that uh no Brett's
life is a stage
I smoke weed until you die that's right
that's right
[Music]